foreign
in Raleigh North Carolina what's up Dan
hey doing well how are you outstanding
brother what's up
yeah so um I just found out a few weeks
ago that my wife is pregnant with our
first baby all right way to go man can I
cheer for you
sure way to go dude how old are you
I'm 32. I just said way to go dude like
you you accomplished like you did the
high jump or something
um I'll say I'm I'm as a fellow Dad I'm
celebrating with you very cool yeah so
congrats man
um thanks yeah and my my question is
like how do I start preparing now like
to be the best that I can be and in
particular like how do I think about or
reframe some of like my own personal
goals because I don't want to be like
you know I hear a lot of people as you
know later in life like oh I should have
been more oriented towards my family
than career or goals but there's also an
element where like do I have to like put
them all down you know what I mean so
just kind of look for some guidance and
wisdom on how do I
integrate those two things well if that
makes sense okay can I ask you
um can I ask you some direct questions
yeah okay your language that you just
used to to ask your question here's what
it really sounds like
okay sounds like you are excited to be a
dad you love the you love your wife you
love the idea of you already probably
start loving this baby
and you're kind of pissed because you
had stuff that you wanted to do
and we don't have any place in our
culture anymore to say like
like it's happening am I off or am I
right
you're you're like you're on to it I I
wouldn't say that I'm pissed as much I'm
just sort of like okay like a little
bummed out but not I wouldn't say I'm
like angry I'm not like oh my gosh like
you're taking my life away but just sort
of like okay okay I know I need to
rethink this and I'm bummed about it but
how do I like do it both well maybe that
makes sense maybe that doesn't
absolutely absolutely I
absolutely hate this idea that we're not
allowed to have the full spectrum of
feelings anymore or we're some kind of
bad person right
um moms get this a lot too with
they can't stay home with their kids
because you should be out contributing
financially and you can't work because
you should be home with the kids and
dads you know you should be fully
present and never ever look at a
smartphone ever you're a terrible father
and you should be out making six figures
and grinding and crushing and working
out four hours a day nobody can win
anymore right yeah and there's no way to
just say dude I'm really excited and God
Lee had a lot of plans man
and I'm gonna have to change all that
crap up or yeah
um so anyway we'll we'll just say there
so I want to give you permission to have
the full spectrum of feelings as you go
along this this adventure okay yeah you
can really really love this toddler and
be super annoyed with how much it cries
and poops and by the way it poops 10x
what you think it's going to it's
unbelievable how much crap comes out of
a baby it's staggering
um and so
can I ask you this is there is it true
bummed out disappointment or underneath
all of this is there a fear like oh this
is happening I'm about to be a dad
I mean there's definitely a little bit
of that fear
um it happened way faster than you know
like a lot of people will talk about
we've been trying for you know a long
time and it's not and for us it was the
opposite experience so it's definitely a
little bit like we were talking we're
like Hey we're like we want to start
thinking about a family like and then it
just happened really quickly so there's
a bit of like just shock Factor
um got pregnant from just a conversation
man way to go Dan uh it felt that way
fertile Myrtle over there okay so
um what did you have planned
they're like the big ones for me is I'm
just a big Backpacker and like hiker and
so like I've always wanted to do a
through hike of like the Appalachian
Trail or maybe like
um the Pacific Crest Trail or like the W
track and patagon like the adventures
that unfortunately take a good chunk of
time it's not like oh I can just put
this into like my daily routine or
weekly rhythms of life it's like I have
to sort of stop them to do some of those
things
um so it goes like that I was like oh
like I'd be away from my family for five
months to do the at you know
um I think it's that's the majority
because like the goals that I'm like
thinking through it's not like man I
want to like have
a certain amount of money by a certain
age or anything like that it's it's more
of was that yeah is that is that a
realistic
before you had kids was that something
you had on the calendar to do or is that
one of those things that's been floating
out there for a while
it's something that it wasn't on the
calendar but my wife and I were talking
pretty regularly about hey like this is
a goal I really want to do I've read up
on it I've studied it I do backpacking
trips I've like been building up my gear
like it's something I do like want to do
it's not just oh maybe one day that
would be fun like there was like working
and plans towards it even if it wasn't
like on the calendar Okay so
I would say if you're not doing
something like that professionally right
um like let's say you were a touring
musician and you're gonna be on the road
five years or you're an actor and you're
gonna be on the road or you're an
engineer on location and you got to go
away for three months that's life or you
get deployed and you're gone for a year
so think through those moments those
kids do great if they've got a great
Network and there's intentionality and
and connection along the way there
um those kids do great those are those
are situations that people plan for well
in advance and they know they're coming
but I'm I'm actually more concerned
about the financial implications like
you probably can't afford to take a year
a half a year off of work
with a with a little kid right I mean it
just changes the equation up here's what
I didn't know on this side on your side
of parenting
um and for all of you who think hunting
is evil great a high five us support you
hit the fast forward button a couple of
times here okay I always
um
I did not understand how much better I
would feel how much more excited I was
how much more joy I felt
when my son
shot a deer
and I got to see the excitement he put
all that work in he's been practicing
I'm really strict on how much he
practices before he goes out in the
field
and how he felt like he's providing for
the like it was incredible and dude it's
I've never I've always been like The
Jealous Guy
or the No No I get the I'm gonna I'm
gonna get the best spot I'm gonna endude
everything shifted and so what I'll tell
you here is having these goals
incredible working towards them in a
rational way financially time wise
awesome
I almost guarantee that your priorities
will shift
in two to three to four to five years
right dramatically and it's hard to see
it on this side so I would begin to make
this plan very very concrete
how much dollars would it actually take
how much time would it actually take
pick one of the trails and either knock
it out in the next three months or four
months before your kid comes along or
say this is what I want to do when my
son or daughter turns 16 we're gonna do
this adventure together
and right now it doesn't feel like that
would be cool
I promise you my son and I are going on
a big elk hunt in December with some
great friends we met in Utah
dude I never in a million years thought
I'd want a 12 year old tagging along
with me and I can't wait now
yeah totally different you know what I'm
saying and if I come home with nothing
and I got to spend that time with my son
incred like I'm I'm so excited about it
um it has nothing to do with the big
goal that I've always been chasing does
that make sense
no yeah I think that makes sense of and
I think it's helpful to hear because I
think
uh one piece of context is that like my
parents didn't bring me into a lot of
like the things that they loved to do
like when I was like a kid it was sort
of the like I felt like my parents were
like we have to be good parents so like
you know and they were like they ran me
around to like soccer and like they
cared for me really well and provided
for me really well and I have great
relationships with them now but it was
always like I didn't feel like we were
like I didn't really know what my
parents loved doing and so like I
haven't had that picture of like hey
like how would how do you integrate like
your kids into like some of the things
that you love doing whether that's you
know hiking backpacking or hunting for
you right so yeah so to hear your
perspective on that dude
um
some of the my greatest memories as a
child my dad his side hustle when I was
a kid this is gonna sound crazy this is
many many years ago but his side hustle
was catching
venomous snakes and he had a friend who
was a taxidermist and he would sell the
wow
and so I have memories and photos of me
and my dad when I was four and five and
six out in the woods Woods Woods
and heart racing fast you know getting
nervous watching my dad do his thing and
dude I became obsessed with catching
snakes when I was a kid became a reptile
goofball my brother got in on it then my
brother became the director of a reptile
house at a zoo and then now my son has a
snake in his wreck it created a legacy
and here's what it was my dad brought me
alongside something that he loved doing
mm-hmm when my dad took me shooting with
him when my dad played catch with me
outside like the greatest gift you can
give your kid is not signing him up for
another travel sport I don't care how
much they beg
the greatest gift you can give your kid
is to teach them what passion and joy
and fun looks and feels like
dude if you start taking your kid on
small backpacking trips before they can
even talk or walk in one of those
backpacks with their feet hang out you
know what I mean like the oh yeah those
things are so cool dude dude you're
teaching your kid love for the outdoors
they're gonna feel the Joy on you
mm-hmm and the greatest gift dads can
pass along to their kids is oh Dad loves
life
this is the thing that bring Dad's Joy
whether you're fixing a car whether
you're going hiking whether you're going
hunting whether you're playing chess and
like I also love playing guitar my kids
have opted out of that I tried man I've
tried and tried and tried and tried they
don't want anything to do with that's
totally cool but they do know dad's got
his things
right right and when I'm downstairs in
the in the garage jamming too loud and I
got the amps turned up too loud and I'm
just pretending I was a high school
metal star which I always wanted to be
come on somebody make this happen for me
um they roll their eyes but they smile
you see what I'm saying so yeah pass
along those take your kids with it's
going to be amazing dude and it's not
gonna be the same Adventure that you
thought and I don't have any hesitation
or promise if your kid got to watch you
save money
and exercise and work out
and build up to a huge trip that they
were too small for but you went on for
three months
right if you bring them along maybe not
on the trip but you bring them along on
the planning on the building stages
you're teaching them how to read a
topographic map you're looking at
pictures on the internet of where Dad's
gonna be you have a little thing on the
wall that shows how much money you're
saving As you move up
um they go on miniature hikes to train
with you you know what I mean before the
big hike and they wish you goodbye and
you and your wife have this all squared
away financially and child care wise and
all that dude that's awesome and you
come back and show the pictures to your
kids that's fantastic man my kids don't
fully understand what I do when I'm out
on the road like I can say hey I'm
meeting with Business Leaders behind
closed doors
they're like okay okay whatever or I'm
speaking at this event okay whatever
I've started now and I speak at Live
Events I just get a quick video on stage
of the crowd screaming and hollering so
I take that and show that to my kids and
they're like oh that's what you're doing
from your eyes out to the audience right
so I bring them along with me even
though they're not there that's okay
if you start hiding from your family
because raising a kid's heart man it's
hard you don't know what you're doing
and there's not a lot of men who will
talk to you about how to do it right
if you start using hiking if you start
using planning for this imaginary
fantasy hike that you're never going to
go on you're going to go on when you're
80. as a way to distract yourself or
numb yourself from the realities of
parenting that's when it becomes an
addiction it becomes a problem
and that's when your kids begin to say
hey loves whatever he's planning over
there more than me
and that's no bueno that's not good
um it doesn't sound like you and let me
go by Circle back to the beginning it's
okay to be disappointed it's okay to
think ah I want to have a million
dollars I want to have graduated college
I wanted to have whatever cool that's
all real and good and true
and you're gonna be a dad
so incredible man everything in your
life is going to change it's gonna be
the worst best thing that ever happened
to you it's going to be the funnest most
exhausting thing that's ever happened to
you and you're going to have to go down
a rabbit hole to figure out who you
really are welcome to the adventure my
brother it is excitement from here on
out